so I'm here with Jake Wallace Simons
thank you for having us intelligent
squared and we're going to uh be
debating And discussing the
very straightforward and in no way
complicated thorny or emotive issue of
Israel and in this case Jake's very
interesting new book is relaphobia which
I can show you here now uh Jake is Jake
what assignments is the editor of the
Jewish Chronicle
um which in many ways makes him the sort
of Dean of of anglo-jewish Journalism
it's it's the job in some ways you're an
ambassador to the community Jake
um he's also a writer for The Spectator
and was well known as a foreign
correspondent at the daily mail before
that
um this is a really interesting book
because it takes on
some really really difficult themes some
really naughty themes about Israel about
how we perceive Israel about how we talk
about Israel and what Jake I think is
trying to do in this book is get us to a
place where really we start to look at
Israel as a country like any other we
start to judge it in the way that we
judge ourselves or other countries and I
think Jake and others
um often feel that we don't assess
Israel in that way that we actually
assess Israel rather differently
sometimes unfairly even
um with a different set of metrics uh
and some of these metrics can be infused
with prejudices
um some of which we may not even realize
are there so so we're going to get into
all of that now
um Jake hi great to be with you thank
you
um so I think I'd like to start actually
by asking you a very traditional
journalistic question which is why you
wrote this book
um why did you want to step forth onto
the fiery coals of the Israel debate
um and what what sort of
maybe it was in your positions at the
Jewish Chronicle and your assessment of
the the Israel debate in the media but
what what really
inspired you to take the leap here
well I think partly it was because I was
missing my life as a foreign
correspondent getting tear gas on the
West Bank and being kidnapped and shot
at and all the rest of it and so I
wanted to have a metaphorical experience
of a similar thrill
um but um but apart aside from that the
the impetus for the book uh came from it
started really in 2021
when there was that operation Israeli
operation against uh the terrorists in
Gaza principally Hamas if you recall uh
there are about 3 000 Rockets shot into
Israeli territory Israeli retaliation
not on not with the Infantry Invasion
but airstrikes
um and in that conflict uh 256
Palestinian Palestinians were killed uh
mainly uh combatants but some civilians
and a number of Israeli civilians a
small number of Israeli civilians were
killed as well
and at that time there was lots going on
in the world uh in Syria 500 million
people 500 000 people half a million
people
had been killed in the Civil War and
according to the UN the world's worst
humanitarian crisis was in Yemen where
thousands of people have been killed in
that uh brutal War including 10 000
children killed or maimed and a good
portion of the country pushed into
malnutrition and starvation
and yet it was the 256th Palestinians
mainly combatants who were killed in a
defensive war that Israel weighs or
defensive action that Israel took that
led to tens of thousands of people
coming out onto the Streets of London
and capitals around the world there was
a demonstration in Hyde Park that was
attended by a hundred and eighty
thousand people
and these demonstrations were not simple
political demonstrations like you would
see against brexit or some other issue
they were infused not everybody who
attended but many of the people were
infused with a almost an unreconstructed
Jew hatred there were gangs of people
patrolling the back streets shouting we
want the zionists where are the Zions we
want their blood there were uh carloads
of people patrolling through Jewish
areas with megaphone shouting about how
they were going to rape Jewish children
and lots more examples of the basis due
hatred
um and this got me thinking about the
whole phenomenon how disproportionate
the the attention is upon Israel
um and also the related question of the
distinction between anti-Semitism and
anti-zionism which led me to want to
popularize this third idea of
israelophobia
yeah I remember those protests very well
I somewhat I have no idea why I decided
to put on a yamaka and go and sort of
walk around them just to see if anyone
hassled me which is the kind of idiotic
thing I'd like to do sometimes but and
no one did but you're right there were
some very alarming uh videos on social
media but other Jews were hassled other
Jews were yeah I think I'm just really
sort of tough and scary and people
didn't want to touch it
um but no it was there were some very
alarming incidents around those protests
um so you know we'll get into some of
the
trickier bits of it later but but
tell me you've you've taken this term as
relaphobia which you haven't invented
out of whole cloth but you're sort of
popularizing it with this book
um we have other terms we have
anti-zionism we have people who just say
I'm anti-israel uh as a political Point
uh and then we have anti-Semitism so why
do we have a new term what does it mean
well I mean like you say the the the
terms that we have at our disposal uh
here too uh are anti-Semitism number one
anti-zionism
and maybe non-zionism
um and that's it but the main two are
anti-Semitism and anti-zionism
and anti-Semitism is an interesting one
because it was invented in the late 19th
century
um around the time that Zionism the word
Zionism was invented actually
um but it began as a phenomenon of of
Jewish of hatred of Jewish people
obviously much much longer before that
thousands of years ago
uh and semitism began with a with a
religious hatred of Jews as the killers
of Christ in in Christendom and as the
infidels in the Muslim world
uh but in the 20th century it became a
race-based hatred
um where Jews were seen as the unter
mentioned the the inferior race that had
to be exterminated for the good of
mankind
um but these days the same animus has uh
you know those with the decline of
religion and the discreditation of
racism that came with the Holocaust
anti-Semitism has had to morph and find
a new uh lexicon a new means of
expression that would allow it to
continue to thrive without being
recognized as a bigotry
uh and so it's attached itself to hatred
of Israel which brings me on to
anti-zionism
the problem with the term anti-zionism
is that many people who are
anti-zionists don't feel there's
anything wrong with being anodized with
being against Israel because in their
mind Israel is a white supremacist
ethnic cleansing apartheid genocidal
Rogue State all of which are untrue
but they in their minds they're
campaigning against a great evil and
that's why they are anti-zionists and
whenever there's something like you know
an event an anti-semitic event a hate
event like the protest that I described
just now
uh there's it always leads to Jewish
people and their allies as it were
accusing the perpetrators of
anti-Semitism to which they respond I'm
not anti-semitic I'm only anti-zionist
or anti-israel and here are my slightly
eccentric Fringe hard left Jews who
agree with me and who give me an alibi
for that and so well and then the debate
becomes about that terminology rather
than about the act of hatred itself and
I wanted to start using the term
israelophobia to avoid that sort of uh
sort of Thicket of complexity of
terminology and just recognize that if
you are attending a protest and shouting
about how you want to find zionists and
you want their blood
you are filled with hatred and that is
the problem and that is why I thought
israelophobia was a clearer term to pin
down that bigotry
so
an obvious point that a lot of people
who are at that protest will make is
that you are picking the worst actors or
that you are highlighting the worst
actors who were there and the worst
things that they said that's not to for
a moment excuse them but you know there
will be a lot of people who went to that
protest who
see a lot of pictures coming out of
Gaza
who look at the asymmetric death tolls
as they see them who feel that there is
a broader Injustice being perpetrated in
the region and that the Palestinians
were on the wrong end of it and that
it's a worthy cause to protest and just
because there are people on the extremes
of that protest that say
horrible things and have horrible
intentions
um that doesn't
undermine the overall point
um and and they will potentially say
well you're sort of tiring me as
israelophobic well actually I don't hear
as well I just think that they need to
give the Palestinians a state I think
they need to you know use less violence
uh in their occupation of the West Bank
or whatever the the framing would be uh
is that a fair critique
it's a very good point and I want to be
very clear about this I'm not saying
that attending that protest alone makes
you israelophobic or anti-semitic I'm
not saying that campaigning for the
Palestinians defending their rights and
believing in their cause is in any way
invalid or wrong or bad or israelophobic
or antisemitic I'm not objecting to
criticism of Israel at all
as long as it's reasonable what I'm
trying to do is find the Overton window
within which debate is reasonable and
fact-based and Define the sorts of
markers of israelophobia when things go
beyond that having said that
the we cannot cannot ignore the scale of
those protests why does the killing of
256 people in combat
with a democracy uh taking action
against a terrorist regime why does that
evoke the passions of 180 000 people in
Hyde Park whereas as I said the
Milestone was passed of half a million
people in Syria who were killed almost
all of whom were Muslims many of whom
were Palestinians Palestinians were
being Barrel bombed in the refugee camps
in Syria by Assad's forces you didn't
see
180 000 people in Hyde Park protesting
about that why are they so much more
animated by the killing of 256
Palestinians by Jews rather than
thousands of Palestinians via Assad
is it is it about the victims or is it
about the perpetrators
I'm not saying that that people need to
take on their causes on a proportionate
sort of robotic way on account of death
tolls there are different things that
stir different passions I understand
that I'm not saying it's invalid to
campaign for Palestinians I'm asking a
deeper question of what's the position
of this conflict in our culture that
causes such uh such passions to to arise
and what which parts of that come from
the inheritance of insemitism over 2000
years
so I think that is a fascinating
question and I think we should try to
answer it so uh because because when you
were assessing
this whole debate criticism of Israel
the debate around Israel the media it
really does come down to this point of
proportionality is Israel treated
disproportionately or it's misdemeanors
and crimes treated differently to other
countries I think the answer is often
yes
but the question you raise is why
and
I can think of lots of reasons that
aren't israelophobia or anti or or
anti-semitic I can think of reasons such
as
um it's such an emotive Place Jerusalem
and Israel and and all of us have some
emotional spiritual connection ancestral
connection to it in some ways
um I can think of the fact that it's
such a long-running conflict and that
you know Palestinians can say well
actually we lost our homes in 1948 here
we are 70 years later we still don't
have them
um I can
think to the fact that um this is
something Jon Snow the the broadcaster
Channel 4 once told me rather surprised
me when I asked him this question and he
said
um I look at Israel and I think they
ought to know better I think they're but
for the grace of God go I and somehow
that Israel is viewed as a western state
and held to a different standard perhaps
than than the Palestinians that struck
me as a form of sort of benevolent
bigotry almost but
there are lots of reasons there's also
you know a very
there's a very long-running PR wall
being waged between Israel and the
Palestinians and some might argue the
Palestinians are better at it
um some might say the opposite
clearly amid all these other factors
there is
something else going on at times and
that's the thing that you're really
focusing on so tell us a little bit
about what the other thing you think is
going on and how you think it shapes our
understanding
well I think that all those factors that
you described
uh are not necessarily separate from
israelophobia or the inheritance of
anti-Semitism I think a lot of them are
tinged by that or even powered by that I
mean it's fascinating to hear you say
that Jon Snow made that comment saying
they should know better I mean let's
let's sort of as I say put a pin it put
let's put a pin in that yeah I'm going
to come come back and I'll I'll wind my
I'll thread my way back to I'll weave my
way but sorry I'll get back to that um
uh but I think that you're right to talk
about the special significance that
Israel has I mean in in the book I'm
pleing for it to be treated like a
normal country but at the same time I
acknowledge that that is never really
going to happen because there are two
israels
as sorbello put it in His Brilliant book
on Jerusalem from 1970 whatever it was
four or five
there are two Israel's the first is
territorially insignificant
it accounts for about a a quarter of one
percent of the entire Middle East has a
population that's smaller than London
about the size of New Jersey economy
about the size of Nigeria
um it it doesn't it doesn't really
matter that much from from one point of
view
from the other point of view this that's
that's the Israel of of facts and of
figures but the second Israel is the
Israel of the imagination and of culture
and that is the Israel that saw Bello
described as as broad as all of history
and perhaps as deep as sleep and and
it's that it's that powerful
the Jerusalem of William Blake you know
the the Jerusalem of Richard the
lionheart it goes back all the way to
the Bible where the Jews received they
were the chosen people they received the
word of God
Christianity came along and turned the
the Jewish homeland into the Holy Land
turned the Jewish City into the holy
city and a Jewish Prophet into the son
of God
and as it turns out that the gravest and
most sort of unacceptable betrayal was
that the chosen people were the very
ones to kill the Son of God and that has
led
to this combination of demonization and
fetishization of Jews being seen
simultaneously as the Uber mentioned and
the unter mentioned the the superhumans
who are behind you know World politics
who control Finance who control the
media who control us all but also the
most despicable mischievous conniving
scheming blood sucking sort of uh
sub-humans and those two things
intertwined over so many centuries in
Christian culture we can talk about
Muslim culture separately but in the
West in Christian culture that it's
really is a big part of the backdrop uh
to many people of the way way in which
we see the world I mean we saw there's a
couple of German economists who did a
study uh in Germany that showed that
areas of Germany where Jews were burned
at the stake in the 14th century because
they were blamed for the black death in
those same areas 600 years later people
were more likely to vote for the Nazis
and that's despite the fact that Jews
hadn't been in those areas for 400 of
those 600 years so this stuff runs very
very deep and when it comes to Israel
all of those emotions are triggered all
of those things are brought to the
surface if we come back to where I put
the pin in the beginning Jon Snow's
comment but they should know better they
should know better I mean that's such a
wonderful colloquial way of saying we
hold Jews to a different standard and to
me it resonates with those centuries of
of of of of of the Western Christian
gays upon the figure of the Jew
demanding that he's better but also
perceiving him to be worse uh you know
as Roald Dahl famously anti-semitic uh
famously said that he criticized the
Jews as he put it lining up for the gas
Chambers and said if it was me I'd have
I'd have gone down fighting I'd have
taken a couple of them with me
but then he also loathed Israel which
doesn't take any dissent and stands up
for itself and Shen sends its fighter
planes to swoop over Auschwitz in a sign
of never again so Jews are seen as sort
of both overly victims and overly
powerful and all of this combines I
think into the perception of Israel
today
so an argument you hear a criticism you
hear of Israel and people who support
Israel is that they use anti-Semitism
and we might Now call Israel
israelophobia too and they say they use
it as a shield and that yes it exists
and you know yes it is a long-running
historical cancer really on
you know on on the west and elsewhere
um but
you know that doesn't excuse certain
things that Israel do and it doesn't
excuse their seemingly unwillingness or
inability to find a path to a fair
settlement with the Palestinians they're
willingness to this is an argument I'm
not necessarily making myself but
um is there a danger with that that for
even everything you identify being
correct that it's all out there but that
it becomes a crutch or it becomes a
shield I don't know what the right
metaphor is but if it comes an excuse
not to self-interrogate for Jews for
Israel for zionists that it becomes
um
you know it puts because it puts you in
a defensive Crouch and therefore you
don't need to sort of
assess your own wrongdoing or your own
misgivings I mean do you worry about
that at all
um I don't have a concern about that for
the following reason that the there is
more criticism of Israel inside Israel
than there is anywhere else I would say
uh Jews are
um as as the famous quote uh has it uh
like everybody else but more so and that
applies to criticism as much as anything
else and in Israel there is a free press
still
um that's engaged in a boisterous debate
day in day out week in week out that
frequently becomes overheated and almost
hysterical particularly at the moment
with all the crisis that's going on
politically
um and in my book I include some
criticisms of Israel it's not my book
isn't isn't trying to defend Israel from
criticism it's not trying to make
pro-israel arguments on individual
points it's trying to identify the terms
of the debate and what's reasonable and
what isn't but nonetheless I include
some criticism of Israel if it's of it's
um particularly of its attitude towards
official attitude towards its Arab
citizens but you know Christians I mean
the political system in Israel is a
total mess it's a total mess
proportional representation one chamber
of parliament overly powerful Supreme
Court you know that and and all of this
has really come to the fore over the
past year and and you know it deserves
and needs a lot of criticism
um so I don't feel that the I the the
idea that Jews can can identify
anti-Semitism when it's coming at them
or israelophobia when it's coming at
them means that they're less inclined to
interrogate their flaws themselves so
I think it'd be good to sort of um flesh
out the israelophobia argument a bit
more so in your book you identify kind
of three stages of israelophobia if you
like uh demonization weaponization and
falsification I wondered if you might
just take us through those three steps
and and how the argument evolves
sure
um I'll do it I'll do it quickly so
demonization uh is really what I was
talking about earlier about the
disproportionate focus on the world's
only Jewish state to the exclusion of
other far worse human rights abuses
occupations Wars and genocides elsewhere
in the world
um the uh and the perception of the of
Israelis as the modern day blood-sucking
Jews and we see those tropes coming
through again and again for example uh
only a couple of weeks ago when the
Israel Defense Forces went into Janine
on the West Bank with a in a
counter-terror operation and killed I
think it was about 12 or so uh
terrorists uh in in a in a firefight uh
not a single civilian was killed it
later turned out that two of those
terrorists were 17 years old rather than
18 years old and this led a BBC
presenter to say on air that the Israeli
the Israel is happy to kill children
which to me felt very resonant of the
ancient medieval blood libel that had
Jews kidnapping Christian children to
kill them and use their blood in their
cooking so it's those sorts of tropes
and you see this disproportionality all
over the place I mean in the United
Nations even you know the U.N Human
Rights Council in its code of practice
it mandates that only one issue needs to
be discussed at every single meeting in
article 7 specifies that only one
conflict needs to be discussed and no
prizes for getting guessing which that
conflict is as a result Israel's being
condemned more than twice the num that
number of times of every other country
in the world so that's demonization
weaponization is I alluded to it earlier
as well it's the way that anti-Semitism
uh takes on the the the language of its
time as a trojan horse for expressing uh
bigotry and hatred uh and without being
recognized as such so in the 20th
century people were able to talk in
pseudo-scientific terms about Jews being
an inferior race which then led to the
justification of their extermination
um you know the SS officers were led to
believe they were doing a good thing
they were taking on a a tough job to
kill men women and children for the good
of mankind
um and similarly these days and semitism
or israelophobia often inhabits the
language of social justice of
anti-racism you know so Israel is blamed
for being a colonialist power for
example one of the worst sins of the uh
of the social justice movement even
though quite clearly historically Israel
is a post-colonial state you know it's
accused of being a white supremacist
State again another of the main sins of
the social justice movement even though
more Israelis are non-white than are
white
um it's accused of apartheid all the
rest of it apartheid you know even
though that's not true we can talk about
that if we want if you want to it's a
use of genocide even though the
Palestinian population has increased
five-fold since Israel was established
so is it but but but you but talking
about uh you know Israel criticizing
Israel in this sort of swivelied
obsessive way but with the language of
social justice makes it sound legitimate
and virtuous and that's weaponization
those terms have been weaponized and
finally falsification
refers to uh the source of these sorts
of false tropes that I've just talked
about Zionism is racism Israel is like
the Nazis uh is a white Colonial settler
State carrying out genocide etc etc
all of those falsehoods which are
clearly untrue if you just go to Israel
have a look I mean where's the genocide
where are the execution pits there
aren't any you know for example it
should be clear as day
but the reason that they have uh gained
such a purchase on on our culture is
because they were created by huge
propaganda efforts by the Soviets during
the Cold War and prior to that by the
Nazis and these were gigantic
state-sponsored attempts to seed these
lies into the consciousness of of the
Middle East and the West uh so the
Soviets in particular created I mean for
example the apartheid slur which I just
alluded to just now
it might come as a surprise to viewers
to learn that the allegation that Israel
was an apartheid state was fabricated by
the Soviets in conjunction with uh
certain figures in the in the Arab
leadership
uh years before there was a single
Israeli on the West Bank
so if you say that the occupation as it
were of the West Bank is nepartheid act
then why was the accusation being used
before there was any such occupation
before 1967.
um and all of these tropes were you know
were spread into the west by millions of
leaflets thousands of newspaper
broadcasts uh they were they were
threaded through Russian diplomacy
Soviet diplomacy all around the world my
book has a lot more detail about that
but these are these three qualities of
demonization weaponization and
falsification are the main sort of
pillars of israelophobia
so I'm going to gird myself and get into
this apartheid point with you because I
do think it's quite an interesting one
it's been in the news lately and I think
it captures a lot of this
a lot of the tensions that exist that
you're looking at
um
you're right to point out that the
apartheid label was there before the
occupation
but so one might argue that just because
that's the case and just because it was
spread by Bad actors doesn't mean that
it is irrelevant today
um it was notable to me that um
someone called Benjamin pogrund a very
famous South African journalist Jewish
South African journalist wrote recently
I think in hertz newspaper
um that he's for decades resisted this
analogy
um but that he now felt and this is just
his opinion but he now felt that
was no longer an analogy he could resist
um and that
uh and if you look at the definitions of
apartheid it's it's a lot of it is about
intention that does does Israel intend
to resolve the sort of political
inequity that exists for the
Palestinians and one might argue that it
doesn't
um
so
you know is that
just because of its the origins of of
that label being used or is it actually
um a reasonable critique to make at this
point or can you have a debate that is
fair-minded about this or is it too
mired in as you call it the sort of is
relaphobia and it's kind of quite
nefarious antecedents
well I mean I I wasn't suggesting that
just because just because the apartheid
label was created before uh any presence
on the West Bank that was the only
reason why it's just I'm not I'm not
saying that I'm saying it's a giveaway
uh it's a clue that the verdict was was
already present in the in people's minds
in the minds of Israel's uh most
hate-filled opponents before in advance
of any of any crime
um but is that's not the reason why it
doesn't fit
the reason why it doesn't fit are
uh really the facts on the ground and I
I accept your point that uh at the
moment with everything that's going on
with the extremists in these in the
Israeli government and the controversies
over the judicial reform and the
Democratic crisis that's engulfing the
country more and more people on the
Jewish side of the fence are on the
Israeli side of the fence are reaching
for
um terms like apartheid in the
escalation of rhetoric
um that's that's taking place in the
country
um but in my view many of the people in
Israel who are beginning to use that
term are doing so because they have
nowhere else to go in the escalation of
rhetoric and they mean it it that it's
sort of they're using it as an in an
instrumental way as part of the debate
with the people on the right who which
who which as they perceive it are in a
sort of battle to the to the political
death I don't think that they
um outside of the bubble of Israel I
don't think they many of them really
fully understand the significance of
that slur and that lie uh in in the
diaspora and around the world in the
International Community
and the reason that it's it's untrue
look
there's there's two there's two we can
split this into two there's Israeli Arab
citizens Arab citizens of Israel and
then there are the Palestinians on the
West Bank
and in Gaza and again this is a very
long discussion but we'll just do it
very quickly yeah um uh that the Arab
citizens of Israel I mean the the
un partition plan in 1947-48
that allowed for the creation of a
Jewish State and a Palestinian State
alongside it which as we all know the
Jewish style acceptors and the
Palestinians instead rejected and waged
war against the Jewish state to try to
complete Hitler's genocide um sounds
like an exaggeration but it's true if
you look at my book give you the details
of that
in that partition plan there was a
provision for an Arab minority inside
Israel
and a Jewish minority inside the
Palestinian state
fast forward to today you have an Arab
minority in Israel 20 of the population
is is is is Arabic
you do not have a Jewish minority on the
way uh under Palestinian control on the
West Bank living under Palestinian rule
because they would get massacred
where's the apartheid
in Israel as a Democratic Society of
course there is racism there is racism
in Britain you know I was looking the
other day at some stats black kids are
six times more likely to be strip
searched in school than white kids in
Britain is that racism we can have a
debate about that but certainly if that
was happening in Israel people would say
it's a racist white supremacist state
when Israel Israel has racism
but to escalate that as evidence of
apartheid is wrong the majority of the
footballers in Israel's national team
have been Arabic
an Arab Israeli is at the head of
Israel's biggest bank an arab-israeli
judge has sentenced a former Israeli
Prime Minister to prison for corruption
this is not apartheid in any meaningful
sense of the word as we saw in South
Africa now let's move across to the
situation on the West Bank
um again too much to talk about but in a
few sentences
the
um disturbing things that you see on the
west back and I was there just a few
weeks ago the the partition wall the
checkpoints the um the security
infrastructure it's there because of
security to protect the Jewish
communities who were there on the West
Bank
it is there to protect against the
terror threat now without going into
whether the Jewish Community have the
right to be there that's a whole other
discussion
but those measures are not in place
to uh to to enforce a legal system that
places Palestinians under Israeli
Dominion as a second class race
they are there to protect Israelis from
terrorism I mean take the take the
division War for example if you recall
back to the second interfada before the
war was was built there will wave upon
wave of suicide bombings almost every
week there was a suicide bombing in
Israel creating Untold Devastation and
killing many many people after the war
was built there have been zero pretty
much zero suicide bombings
now opponents of Israel might not like
the War I don't like the wall nobody
wants to see a wall there but I like
suicide bombings less
um and so this is an overview look
there's a lot to talk about but you get
my general gist of why the apartheid
slur is inappropriate and as a final
coder I would just say that there are
parts of the world that do fit the
apartheid label I mean look at China's
occupation of Tibet that is a full fat
occupation shall we say started in the
50s
in Tibet
Tibetans are not allowed to speak their
national language children have been
kidnapped and sent to re-education camps
to be reprogrammed to be Chinese showing
the Tibetan flag is it will land you in
prison wishing the Dalai Lama a happy
birthday will land you in prison secret
police run every element of Tibetan life
to make it Chinese
it was an invasion of a Sovereign Nation
in the 50s by another Sovereign Nation
China this is an apartheid
South Africa obviously wasn't apartheid
segregation in America could qualify for
the term aparted as well where blacks
and whites were not allowed to use the
same facilities none of this is true of
Israel situation Israel is complicated
it's ugly in many cases and it's
unpleasant but it does not qualify for
the slur of Apartheid
so uh just before I've got a couple more
questions and then we're going to move
to audience questions so if anyone in
the audience wants to put in some
questions now is your chance
um
the phrase one often hears Jake in this
debate is um you know in response to
some of what you just said is is what a
boundary
and for those of you who aren't well
versed in online discourse what a
battery is really a phrase about
people using
other examples to deflect from their own
case so what about this what about China
what about India Etc
now
I've got my own problems with this
phrase because actually I think it's
very important how different things are
assessed and and calibrating between
them can be very revealing but
what do you make of it I mean what do
you think if someone says oh this is
just water battery let's forget China
what about Israel what about what Israel
is doing let's just assess that why
can't we protest that why do we have to
protest China at the same time Israel's
a lot closer Britain's had a very strong
historic role in in Palestine and Israel
so
isn't that what about Siri
yeah I mean I I
oh let's turn the thing on its head if
if we go back if we if we agree as I
hope that most people will that there is
clear evidence of a double standard with
regard to Israel
uh such as at the UN for example which
is clear discrimination Israel the only
country to be singled out for criticism
at every meeting of the unhcr
condemned twice as as many times as
every other country in the world
combined the clearest example of
international double standards
how am I supposed to
illustrate that to make that argument
if I'm not allowed to say there are
other countries who are fast far worse
who aren't being focused on at all if
that's called what a battery it's
impossible to make that argument so what
I'm trying to do is not say that it's
okay
for uh you know to to excuse to sort of
repress criticism of Israel because
other countries are worse I'm not saying
that as I've said many times it's good
to criticize I mean Israel I mean not
good it's it's part of life it's natural
to criticize Israel as you would
criticize any other country in the world
Israel is a in some ways
a normal country in some ways it's
alongside other countries as jabatinsky
put it one of the fathers of the modern
State Israel uh needs to who deserves to
have its own Heroes but also its own
villains needs to be allowed to have its
own villains without being condemned
without being called upon as sorbello
put it to uphold the moral burden that
the rest of the world has dumped
[Music]
what about you it doesn't mean that I'm
saying no criticism of Israel uh it's um
what about we sort of it implies that
I'm trying to deflect attention from
criticism of Israel onto other countries
that's not the case I'm simply calling
for a bit of proportionality in our
assessment of the international
situation
you know it's interesting there's a
piece I wrote for your Jewish Chronicle
impact once about the the idea of Israel
being a light unto the Nations which is
a very
resonant phrase
um from the book of Isaiah that has
lived throughout sort of Jewish and
Zionist debate and I think sometimes
Jews are also guilty of expecting a
different standard from Israel of
wanting it to be this sort of city on a
hill that doesn't
um get its hands dirty the way other
countries might you know I think that's
not just uh critics of Israel sometimes
it's Israel's keenest supporters who who
hold it to a higher and maybe impossible
standard
I I agree I mean um Jews do uh you know
hold themselves to very high standards
and there is this in the culture
um and this exists in Israel perhaps
that powers a lot of the debate that
happens and the criticism that happens
within Israel itself and that's not a
problem really it's good to have high
standards and so on so on and so forth
but it's a problem when it becomes
flipped and used in bad faith and that's
where israelophobia comes in
um we should say
um uh Josh you mentioned the word
Zionist quite a lot
um I think to many people the word
Zionist has negative associations I
don't know whether you want to clarify
that before or talk about it a little
before we go to questions well yeah I
mean yeah we'll make this our last point
because we've got some interesting
questions coming in um I think that
uh the word Zionist has been demonized
in some corners of the West in our
society
um to my mind it when I use it and I
would describe myself as a Zionist it's
on a basic level just supporting the
existence of a Jewish state in Israel
but obviously there are lots of
different types of Zionism and
manifestations of it
um some quite extreme some very moderate
um but it has it had it is a term that
has been I would say you know weaponized
and demonized
as per your sort of uh menu in your book
um in a way I actually find designers in
point
you know in a way it's almost I'm almost
a post Zionist and I don't mean that in
the sense that I no longer believe that
I just think that actually
I'm not a britishist or a germanist
these are the existence of those
countries and their characteristics are
not really up for discussion Zionism for
me you could argue ends when the state
of Israel is established because at that
point you should
stop thinking of it as an ideology and
start thinking of it's a country but
that is probably a debate we could sit
all afternoon having so I'm going to
move you on to some questions Jake
unless you unless you've got anything to
add to that I've got too much to add to
that so let's go to the question okay
fine let's go to the question there is a
question in from Derek he says uh do you
have a problem with the Israeli
government claiming to be the voice of
Jews globally and this is an interesting
question and it will come up in the
pages of your Jewish Chronicle I'm sure
because some Jews do sometimes feel a
little bit uh defensive about someone
like Benjamin Netanyahu who has been
known to do this uh claiming to speak as
the voice of of global jury there is
obviously no one voice of global jury
there's ten in my own head but
um he has been known to do this
um and it is it is a debate so what do
you think of it
it doesn't doesn't really bother me to
be honest I mean I think that I mean
look I mean let me reverse from that in
principle it doesn't bother me because
Israel is the only Jewish state in
existence it exists because uh it's
intended to give a safe haven to Jews
from persecution which is which is
believed our existence for thousands of
years
um and for that reason it is a leading
Force in World jury and
um has a legitimate claim to have a very
strong voice perhaps the strongest voice
that doesn't mean that everyone's going
to agree with the with what it says or
or like or agree with the person who's
articulating that voice at the time in
the moment I think in principle I don't
have a problem with it but I can see why
when somebody who you you know perhaps
deeply disagree with and many people
even despise Netanyahu increasingly at
the moment I can see why it becomes
problematic to those people but I think
in principle I don't have a problem with
its position as the leading voice
so there's a couple of questions kind of
on this this issue of what about ISM
that we discussed so let's get to a bit
more into it uh Tabitha says what do you
think about Russia using the term
rossophobia that's been around at the
moment or Chinese saying that criticism
of China is anti-chinese or synophobic I
suppose you could call it and do you
worry that these terms can sometimes be
used
to shut down legitimate criticism
I I hear that I see what you mean but I
I would suggest that the case of Israel
is
um very very different from that of
China and Russia because
israelophobia is not something new it is
anti-Semitism it's the same it's the
same thing
the only reason I'm introducing a new
term for it is to clarify the debate
because it becomes eroded by
um discussions of anti-zionism and where
that fits in and the actual core of the
hatred gets lost the core of addressing
the core issue of hatred gets lost
um antisemitism obviously has no
parallel really in in world history in
terms of the depth of the hatred and the
longevity of the hatred and the Sinister
pernicious implications of it and and
you know and the historical antecedence
of it it has no equivalent to no
parallel so I think that what I'm really
talking about is that tradition the way
that ensemitism has found a new home in
israelophobia which is a very different
matter to whatever the Chinese or
Russians are saying
good we've got a couple more questions I
would if anyone else has got a question
on their mind then do please put it in
the Q a box and if you want to tweet
then the hashtag is iq2
um so interesting question on a slight
tangent but I I'd be interested to know
what you think about this question from
Nadia how do you feel about American
Evangelical Christians supporting Israel
and there is a view that some have not
everyone in the Evangelical community
that
um
they support Israel because of their
views about Armageddon and the return of
Christ and they see they see
the Jewish state is a sort of Forerunner
for that uh yeah and
you know this is is a big issue in
American politics but also plays it into
Israel as well what do you make of uh do
you see American evangelicals who are
very pro-israelis allies as supporters
as or did they ever concerning
interesting question I think that
um if I was Israeli and I'm not Israeli
so I'm not speaking in any way on on
even if I was I wouldn't be able to
speak on behalf of Israel but I'm not
Israeli so
um I'm seeing it seeing the whole issue
from the outside but nonetheless
um speaking to Israelis and Israeli
politicians and picking up the discourse
there
the support is not unwelcome because
it's support
and it's a powerful
um it's a powerful source of support for
Israel from from within the United
States and that's that's uh seen as as
welcome and and useful
but I do worry sometimes about you know
it's that as I said before the flip side
of demonization of Jews has been
fascialization of Jews the chosen people
who kill Christ the superhumans and the
sub-humans and I do feel sometimes
threading through the discourse from
from the American Evangelical right is
that they're supporting Jews with that
sort of note of fetishization
particularly if they're doing it to
fulfill their own religious theological
agenda of triggering the Apocalypse in
the second coming of Christ
um you know and doing that by attracting
more and more Jews into Israel to to
cause that prophecy to come true that
feels a little bit cynical doesn't it
can do or certainly as you say
instrumental perhaps and one wouldn't
necessarily want to be an instrument of
the Apocalypse
um
you know it's really interesting the
stuff you say about anti-Semitism it is
it is so mutable I mean you say in your
book you talk about mutation and you
quote the late Rabbi Jonathan sacks the
former Chief Rabbi Britain and a very
sort of iconic figure in anglo-jury and
he talks about in the Middle Ages Jews
were hated because of their religion in
the 19th and earlier 20th century they
were hated because of their race
and today they are hated because of
their nation-state the state of Israel
and I think that's
a little bit of what you're trying to
show as well is is the way that the
hatred is the constant but it's
manifestation
can and has evolved over the years
um
I think there's a really interesting
question here about
social media to that point because
um
social media has obviously impacted all
of this greatly as it has any fiercely
contested political debate what do you
think it's done
to israelophobia to anti-Semitism how do
you think it's affected
The israel-palestine Narrative and how
we all perceive it
I think it's put rocket boosters under
it as it has with all contentious issues
it's allowed the unconscious assumptions
and unconscious bigotries that people
might have you know only expressed
perhaps in private
to be plastered all over the Internet by
people with Anonymous handles
um and that creates this contagion and
this coarsening of the debate and those
sort of mainstreaming of of severe sort
of bigotry
but also it's become the main platform
for propaganda
uh you know it's not just honest people
and private citizens who are having this
debate there are states who are pumping
propaganda onto Twitter or X onto
Facebook uh all the time in huge
quantities and principle of those at the
moment with regard to Israel is Iran
uh I've done some some work in my
journalism exposing some of the fake
news sites and fake accounts and and
sort of troll factories that are run by
Iran to flood the internet with uh with
this sort of Israeli phobia uh which is
often often regurgitated by useful
idiots uh on often on the hard left and
his Echo Chambers online and then spills
out into the mainstream narrative and
becomes picked up by people who
um hold us a suite of beliefs described
as Rob Henderson uh as luxury beliefs
this sort of you know at the moment if
you have if you are if you are a member
of the educated Elite at the top of an
institution in Britain you are likely to
have certain identifiable positions on
colonialism on slavery on Race on
transgender and also on Palestine and
they can often begin to regurgitate some
of this propaganda from online and
siphon it out into the real world so
it's a serious problem and and has
tentacles that reach into all parts of
society
so that's the bad news there might be
some good news however as um someone
asked do you think now that uh Corbin is
gone anti-Semitism is less of an issue
in Britain today I very briefly before
passing on to you would say that I do
think
tempers have calmed and and that some of
the stuff that was being mainstreamed
and legitimized at that time
uh has moved back to the fringes where
it belongs
um what do you think
yeah I mean it doesn't doesn't feel like
that to me personally because over the
past couple of weeks of my book coming
out I've been uh swamped with this sort
of stuff from from those sorts of people
but I think overall I tend to agree I
mean the I think the there was some good
news which came out of the Corbin uh uh
uh sort of cataclysm uh the first piece
of good news of course was that he was
um delivered a a real thumping at The
Ballot Box by the electorate on 12th of
December 2019 but the other part of good
news really was that people began to
talk about anti-Semitism and it really
reinforced how unacceptable it is in
modern Britain
um and people are aware of it now in a
way it's part of the debate when
somebody is accused of anti-Semitism
people take it seriously I remember
before corbyn was elected as leader of
the opposition I was pit and I was at
the Sunday Telegraph I was picturing
stories about him exposing how he was
meeting terrorists at the House of
Commons and so on and so forth and the
editors were not interested because they
said oh that's just Jeremy being Jeremy
well come 2015 and I I got those stories
out and did them and it started the
snowball effect of stories about of
exposures of his positions I think that
people now no one's going to say that's
just him being him people are much more
finely tuned to this sort of stuff so I
think that's that's good and I also
think that the corbinites have faded
largely into the background they have
gone back uh under the rocks from which
they came labor conference last year was
encouraging the labor friends of Israel
event was very well attended by all the
right people The Fringe Jewish voice for
labor corbinite conference was a long
way from the main Conference Center was
poorly attended and felt desperate and
sad and pathetic
um so I think we're we're going back to
normality but I think one thing that the
corbinera has taught us is that this
stuff can Flash up very quickly and we
need to be on my guard against it
so I think I think uh last question
um and you've touched on this a little
bit
um it's something I know that is a
matter of concern around a lot of uh
Jewish dinner tables in Britain and
elsewhere which is the direction of
travel in Israel
um as you say they are in something of a
of a democratic crisis
um
you know you talk to Liberal Israelis
they'll say that Netanyahu and his
allies are trying to turn the country
into some form of autocracy
um others will say that's a bit panicked
and hyperbolic
um but
things are not heading in a great
Direction and and as you pointed earlier
there are extremists in the government
now and these are people that really
shouldn't be anywhere near the leaves of
power in my view at least
um and people who are Jewish
supremacists are vow Jewish supremacists
and and echoing some of the worst of the
rhetoric that you hear on the other side
at times at their worst so do you worry
about the direction of travel and do you
worry about Israel's
hard-run freedoms about its Democratic
rights about backsliding as you say the
Constitution isn't written down it could
take a lot of different forms of
Israel's future so so how concerned are
you and where do you think that might be
going
give a few a few a few thoughts
um firstly I think it's important not to
draw a false equivalence between even
the worst Jewish extremists in the
government and the other side that the
actual terrorists I think that's
important there have been Jewish
terrorists in history they are fairly
few and far between Barack Goldstein in
1994 who massacred Palestinians in
Hebron is one very Vivid example but
that's it's pretty rare I'm not excusing
the the the far right people on the
radicals on the West Bank who bully and
beat up Palestinians on occasion
um uh resulting in loss of life
penalties I'm not excusing that for a
minute those people are beneath contempt
in my view so don't get me wrong here
but I'm saying that to draw this false
equivalent there was a piece actually in
the in the times a few months ago
comparing the Israeli government to Iran
and uh and the Taliban which I think is
totally hyperbolic and outrageous that's
the first thing to say second thing to
say is I'm not saying it's all okay I'm
very deeply disturbed by a lot of what's
happening in Israel
um if Israel as jabotinski put it uh
needs the right to have its own villains
well we're seeing those villains now
um but you know we see we we see in some
ways similar stories playing out in many
other countries across the world
particularly in Europe in Britain we
we're in a privileged position of having
no far significant far-right political
party or political force I mean the
closest we can get I suppose is the
English Defense League or ukip or
national action but nothing in
Parliament we haven't got an equivalent
of alternative for Deutschland in
Germany we haven't got an equivalent to
the Sweden Democrats in Sweden who are
in government now who are the only party
in Europe to have actual Nazi Roots you
know Golden Dawn or Georgia Maloney who
is there's a debate to be had about her
but she's clearly a populist in charge
of Italy and many many others I mean
there are so many examples of the
Resurgence of the populist rights across
uh across Europe and indeed in the
United States which I think I think
Trump was really the motherload of this
movement and there's a lot of
cross-fertilization between Trump and
the Norms that he established
and Israel and what's going on in
Israeli politics today so
I think that
um yes it's worrying and it's disturbing
it's part in a way of a trend that's
occurring across the world
um it's important to keep it in
proportion with regard to Israel's
enemies and indeed the autocracies and
dictatorships that surround Israel none
of which have has even half the number
of freedoms that Israelis have including
Muslim Arab Israelis
um talk you know towards gay people
women and so forth so keep it in
proportion the Jewish people have
survived worse have got through worse
Israel is a democracy the protests are
happening it's a massive democratic
debate there's been no real violence
that the protest thank God so far and
overall I'm optimistic that the Israeli
democratic system is now coming of age
and growing up and this hopefully uh is
the birthing Pains of a new more sane
political era for Israel well I think
your aunt there in a way captures sort
of the central argument of the book
which is that it's not about
pretending these aren't problems or or
ignoring them is about trying to place
them in proportion and and yes when you
look at some of the
far-right populists and their extremist
language in Israel you can draw
parallels with with broader trends that
we are seeing across the world you also
should probably look at them in that
specific local context too but yes yes
um I I think that is a nice summary of
your broader Point
um so yeah keep things in proportion
everyone please
um and Jake it's been a real pleasure to
talk this all through with you again the
budget is relaphobia is here and in all
good bookshops
um and yeah thank you for the
fascinating conversation uh I'm Josh
granty and you've been watching or
indeed listening to Intelligence Squared
and it's been a pleasure to have you
many thanks